[Music]
eric is in charlotte north carolina hey
eric welcome to
the ramsay show hi thanks for taking my
call
sure man what's up um
so i'll just get right down to the
question um the question is instead of
selling our home and taking the equity
and buying an upgrading at home
um is there any reason we shouldn't do a
cash out refinance and remodel our
current home to basically be the home we
would have purchased otherwise
uh well i don't teach people to do to
borrow money
or to borrow more money if you do sell
and you go buy a
different mortgage i guess that has the
same exact effect to your point
um exactly but uh the problem on a
refi on a remodel
is people have a tendency to overbuild
the neighborhood
yes so what's your home worth
today um today probably 100
what would it be worth after the remodel
maybe 120. and what would the remodel
cost
i'm estimating on the high end here
we're probably 40.
okay so you're going to lose half of the
money
oh yeah i understand that right you're
going to spend 40 and you're going to
increase your value 20.
that that would increase i mean that
would include
um repairing a three-car port garage in
the back and turning one of those
carports into a
small apartment which still makes your
property worth 120
probably yeah so you still lost 20 grand
yeah that makes sense missing something
no i think the math on this doesn't add
up it doesn't sound like it's worth
renovating here if he wants to upgrade
and sell the house that's fine but it
doesn't seem like it's worth doing this
cash out refi and doing all these
renovations to only get that much
extra yeah if you could increase the
value at least exactly what
your cost was then we'd have an argument
to have and the next question would be
uh if you have a hundred and forty
thousand dollar home
what is the average are you in a
neighborhood or in a rural setting
it's a very small town in north carolina
okay when people are looking for
one hundred and fifty thousand dollar
houses do they drive down your street or
do they drive down your street looking
for hundred thousand dollar houses
hundred thousand dollars yeah yeah
probably a hundred yeah so my other
point is you're about to overbuild the
neighborhood
so i think your actual analysis at the
beginning was
very good and very correct eric in that
um
i i think you're right i think you're
only going to increase it to 120 and
it's still going to make you one of the
most expensive houses on your street
and that's the very end of the piece of
real estate you don't want to be you
want to be one of the least expensive
homes
in your area because you're going to get
the most increase in value and have the
highest probability of selling it
when you get ready to turn it over and
so george overbuilding the neighborhood
is
the swimming pool edition uh these year
these days
it's the water park in the backyard when
when i was growing up
um on the other side of the tracks a
swimming pool was
actually a swimming pool today when
people don't talk about a swimming pool
it costs more than a house well there's
landscaping there's a slide
and so he's not doing that that's not
what he's doing but sure that's the kind
of stuff that sets you up for
spending four times as much as you're
going to increase the value
and you talk about that in the financial
peace university lesson on real estate
making sure you're not over building go
don't get the most expensive house in
the neighborhood
and if he does this that's what's going
to happen and no one's going to want to
buy the most expensive house in the
neighborhood
yeah i actually just sold my personal
home and i had violated that
you over built one of the reasons that
uh was
you know it's a big stinking house but
uh one of the reasons i sold it
was this hot real estate market was a
good time to undo
that mistake and get out with my skin
intact yeah
but uh it was not the main driving
reason the main driving reason was
sharon says time to move
and we operate around our house on swi
sharon once it's my favorite rule
and so uh you've got whitney wants it
wwe
oh yeah we're feeling that yeah and
that's pretty much what you do if you're
smart man
yes it all comes down to patience